avec nous julie garnier à les oratrices
de la france en swiss
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors la
convergence des nutons on en a parlé
beaucoup on continue d'en parler
beaucoup
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on y était à cette
convergence je crois que ça fait un
moment en fait qu'on y est ce qu'on ne
montre pas à la télé c'est on va dire
toutes ses formes de résistance et qui
existent aujourd'hui manifester est un
acte de résistance et c'est pas pour
rien que le parapluie a été brandie
parce qu'il devient un symbole comme
d'autres symboles on était là comme le
gilet jaune et ce n'est pas pour rien
non plus que le chant des partisans a
été chantée aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
manifester est dangereux et donc c'est
pour ça que l'iliade et des multiples
formes de se mobiliser
vous l'avez vu avec le péage mais
également les gilet jaune était aussi
aux côtés des salariés de honnête envers
l'ancienne et il y a également dans les
entreprises et on n'en parle pas
également une forme de contestation que
ce soit dans des grandes entreprises
comme à total comme à sanofi comme
general electric aux leur renault est la
ré tp edf etc
il y a énormément de contestation
sociale il ya des milliers de raisons
d'être en colère et je crois que oui ça
se voit malheureusement aujourd'hui on
l'a des médias qui font tout pour que
cette convergence mais tu as lu alors on
vous le disait un beaucoup de
contestations la grève dans les
transports manifestations des personnels
fanion de l'éducation nationale de la
plaie des jd jaune selon vous qu'est ce
qui explique ce mécontentement
cette contestation sociale c'est qu'on
est à l'aune d'une hécatombe sociale
déjà on le voit avec la pauvreté ce
week-end si la france est soumise à
organiser des collectes notamment pour
port de jouer parce que il ya un enfant
sur cinq en france qui vit sous le seuil
de pauvreté
entendez le un enfant sur cinq souffre
seuils de pauvreté
et ça c'est que le début c'est que le
début on voit bien que derrière il y a
des plans de suppressions d'emplois qui
qui sont fait toujours au profit des
mêmes il y à un chantage social il ya un
contexte
aujourd'hui on est en train de voir
disparaître tous les boucliers
de protection tous les boucliers sociaux
ce que ce soit dans les conditions de
travail qui sache s étaient les critères
de pénibilité mais également chantage
sociales sur les salaires ce smic qui
n'augmente pas ce rsa qui refusait aux
jeunes alors on sait que les jeunes le
sont les l'une des principales victimes
de cette crise tout ça c'est un contexte
qui est qui font que des gens se sentent
à chaque fois dépourvu le problème
aujourd'hui dans ce pays
c'est le problème qu'il ya des gens qui
se gavent sur cette crise il faut il
faut en être conscient de ça et le
problème c'est que tant qu'on ne
partagera pas alors il y aura toujours
ces ses cris de justice sociale de
justice fiscale parce que ce sont des
cris juste s'ils sont décrites ils sont
faites à partir du quotidien qui montre
que ce n'est plus possible que dans un
même pays il y en a qui gagnent
centaines de milliers d'euros par mois
et qu'il y en a d'autres qui vivent avec
à peine à peine rien croire c'est
impossible on peut pas continuer comme
ça alors dans quelle mesure le
gouvernement peut-il répondre à ces
revendications qui sont multiples le
problème c'est que ça fait pas partie de
son programme c'est que emmanuel macron
malgré ses communications
mais elle ne veut pas faire ça et et
c'est bien pour ça qu'on est face à une
impasse là dessus et politiquement nous
nous faisons des propositions quand nous
dûmes comme nous demandons que le smic
soit réévaluée à 1400 euros quand nous
proposons le par exemple la question de
la bifurcation écologique parce qu'on
sait que elle sera porteuse de nombreux
emplois de centaines de milliers
d'emplois que le but de du travail en
france ce n'est pas de dire aux gens
vous travaillez pas assez mais c'est de
travailler tous travailler mieux nous
faisons des propositions nous n'arrêtons
pas d'en faire
mais face à nous on a quoi on a un
gouvernement qui toute façon est là pour
faire passer des lois et des mesures qui
vont toujours au profit des mêmes et
c'est bien pour ça que quand il ouvre
des négociations plus personne n'y croit
parce qu'on sait très bien que leur
dessein derrière c'est toujours de faire
gagner encore lui même alors je nous ne
sommes jamais gagnant parce que toute
façon ce sont eux qui choisissent les
règles merci je les gardiens d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes oratrice de la france
insoumise marciel